you've really perfected this creepy
stare that you give you give this
amazing stare it's called I think the
brand stare I think we have it there you
have this kind of faraway look and I've
noticed there's a lot of scenes now
where someone you can take that picture
down now we get it you see this these
are so many scenes where someone will
walk into a room and then they'll going
yeah and you're there giving that stare
just a sort of weird guy hanging around
Winterfell staring yeah and like looking
through people the story behind that is
that I'm blind on set I don't have my
glasses and I don't wear contact lenses
so I'm genuinely staring into another
that puts a whole different spin on it
now you just can't see who came into the
room there are all these you're very
popular on the internet there are all
these tremendous internet memes that
involve your character and sort of his
intensity the way you now have this sort
of intense look that you give people and
someone put up have you seen this the
dog running oh yes they they put this up
in response to your character and it's
this fantastic video of I guess their
dog reminds them of Brant let's take a
look
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that dog is really committed to his job
yeah
staring people down there's all these
fan theories and I'm just gonna ask you
to respond to one there's this fan
theory that bran is the night king and I
don't know where that comes from and
obviously you don't have to respond to
that but what do you think they even add
the idea that bran is the night king I
mean I think this theory has been sort
of knocking about for a while and I
don't know how it's got so much traction
and people are kind of convinced that
it's it's absolutely legit I mean I've
literally watched people put two
pictures of my face in his face side by
side and they're like yeah they look
identical this is like really do I do I
really look like an ancient ice zombie
yeah well yeah that's a look at this we
have a picture here I think it's no you
don't you do not it's insulting I don't
think it's right